un homme en train d'être sorti des
décombres un miraculé les services de
secours ukrainien ont passé la nuit à
s'activer pour essayer de sauver des
personnes coincées sous les graves
c'est une maternité qui a été bombardée
le bâtiment de deux étages a été détruit
un nouveau-né est mort dans cette
attaque sa mère vivante mes blessée a pu
être sauvé par les secouristes le
président selinski accuse la Russie de
semer la terreur et d'avoir frappé cette
maternité de vilniansk située à une
trentaine de kilomètres de zaporrija
tout près de la ligne de front
d'après l'Organisation mondiale de la
santé plus de 700 attaques ont touché
des établissements de santé depuis le
début de la guerre en février dernier
438 enfants sont morts sur cette même
période selon le bureau du procureur
général du Crès
et à l'instant l'administration